make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
Spahn part two people have been asking
me to record spawn because of the fact
that spawn is coming out for for Mortal
Kombat 11 and people have been ranting
like screaming about it right like every
single time the comments come in as a
notification on my phone it's like will
you cover spawn will you do more spawn
okay so for those of you guys who were
playing catch-up
we already did spawn part 1 we did it
last year actually and and that one's
there if you guys want to go check it
out and we'll probably create a playlist
up because we're gonna test this where
we're gonna test bed this this whole
week we're gonna do spawn his backup
stories well we're gonna do our main
normal comics that we usually do but
we're gonna have secondary videos that
are all gonna cover spawn leaves a whole
bunch of spawn stuff because I'm curious
to see is it that people really want to
see spawn or is it just like a really
small number of people really want to
see spawns I'm kind of curious about
that with with spawn part 2 this is
really kind of spawn getting into like
the meat and potatoes of what his
characters about the first arc is called
questions really in its like four parts
right so you get the origin of Al
Simmons a spawn that kind of thing and
that's what we cover this what we titled
the video this one is kind of him off to
the races playing his role the funny
thing about this is that this is
probably six issues into it and and back
in the 1990s the character spawn was
part and parcel to how comics existed
back then insofar as the villains were
the most incredible thing ever the cool
thing is it like they got really really
interesting as time went on right so the
way this this initially picks up is we
pick up with a guy named overt kill now
overt kill does not actually get in
origin until you get into the curse of
spawn stories and the curses form was
kind of like a spin-off series so it's
like Punisher and then Punisher wardrobe
a spin-off series based on the character
of spawn but it's designed to kind of
explain a lot of the other characters
that are there this guy overt kill was a
really as a guy named Nicholas who
basically surround thirteen-years-old
sort of making a name for himself is
more or less a hitman for the mob
ultimately he ended up killing the wrong
guy and his head was caved in and then
cybernetic enhancements were offered to
basically fix him and then make him more
capable right so he was like the million
dollar man but as it stands right now
he's really a major force and a major
hitman for the various mobs that are out
there and the reason why that matters is
because overt kill gets his name up from
literally just being over the top right
so he's like the trimmer' brothers from
smokin aces only few guys ever saw that
movie if anything is kind of a pastiche
unlike the over-the-top nature of
characters back during the the early
1990s since the reason why he looks so
advanced is because if you go when you
read Marvel Comics especially Marvel
during the 1990s everybody had
everybody looked all
technologically-advanced uh ant-man is a
perfect example of that he looked like a
Space Marine from alien to but over to
kill kinda gets his name from the fact
that he's literally a one-man army his
enhancements really put him over the top
in comparison to like most conventional
groups that are out there and so the
results of that is what we end up doing
here is basically jumping to a couple of
mob henchmen and the reason why is
because with spawn doing his thing he's
basically been taking out the mob that
what you have here is you essentially
have a scenario whereby Al Simmons when
he was turned into spawn what we covered
in part one if he was kind of stuck
between a rock and a hard place if he
decided to use his powers and to go
forward and to like fight crime and
defeat bad guys and so on and so forth
the energy the finite amount of energy
he has in his body will dwindle down and
then he'll die and then his soul will
belong to mal Bhoja the person that more
or less created him and then he'll lead
the art Lee Malvo his army of Hell spawn
if he does nothing and allows his power
to basically just kind of go on forever
and ever and ever then basically he'd be
standing idly by and watching the world
burn it's kind of an interesting
scenario and that's where you sort of
get into what made spawn so intriguing
right we'll talk about that here in a
minute once we get into the fight
between himself and overt kill but what
you end up having is these various
henchmen who show up and really started
heating up well you know one of these
drug addicts and it's kind of like give
us the rundown on who this guy is like
who it is us taking out our guys so on
and so forth and this guy Freddy
basically responds by saying okay give
me the drugs that I want and then like
I'll give you the information that
you're looking for you know what it's
kinda like no give us the information
we're looking for or we'll kill you and
then we'll give you your drugs if your
information is is worth while of course
once he drops the info they end up
killing him anyway but what he basically
reveals is that spawn is more or less
taking up residence and the various
homeless sectors right this since that's
kind of a cast-off or sees himself that
way and it's kind of cool because when
this information is dropped
to basically a guy named Tony twist he's
the one that kind of says okay
let's go find this guy and let's take
him out right because this guy's taking
out members of our group of our mob the
other Don's the other mob boss is out
there wanting to want this guy taken
care of
he's on our turf it's our job to
eliminate him right otherwise they'll
see Tony twist is weak they'll eliminate
him and replace him with somebody they
think they can get the job done so
because of that what we end up doing is
jumping to to spawn basically when he
ends up you know having a conversation
with a couple of homeless guys and this
is where things get cool right because
what he says here is that when he
listens to these homeless guys talk you
know they're kind of like man you know
you seem kind of weird and kind of
strange and so on you know and I'm sure
you've got a weird story but like we all
have that
who cares what we were before what
matters is who we are now and it's kind
of interesting when you look at this
it's almost like homeless people are
more forgiving of a human being than
like the average person out there right
people are for the most part exceedingly
judgmental you can do whatever you want
in this life so long as I agree with it
but with these homeless guys it's you
have your own story sure but like so do
we and like we've all done terrible
things but that doesn't define who we
are right now right like what makes us
who we are is what we do in this moment
going forward people can change and so
it's kind of interesting that spawn can
find redemption and essentially the
castoffs of society and that's what
makes him feel at home here that's why
he spend so much time hanging around the
homeless population is because one he
can fit in there's already a lot of
people there who look to form so if it
came down to one of those things where
he needed to basically hide his costume
and show his true face and people gonna
be like man that guy looks rough but
like so does John over there - he looks
rough - so like whatever man like
everybody's got scars you know so you
can kind of blend in with the crowd he
can also kind of be at home when Al
Simmons came back you know what we
covered in the first video when he came
back he found that his wife Wanda had
married his friend Harry and started a
family right so he doesn't have a home
there anymore there's nowhere for him to
go back to and so he's just kind of
free-floating in this world now and this
is the only real place he can call home
what this does is it leads to these two
henchmen basically tracking down this
location where spawn was last to have
been believed and in they end up killing
one of the homeless guys and in response
to that spawn basically shows up and
it's kind of like okay one you're gonna
tell me who it is this tracking you and
they're attacking me and then they're
gonna tell me why no this is one of the
things you kind of ran into when it came
to the early dialog of the spawn comics
as cool as spawn is the early writing
was a little rough it was a little like
cliche in terms of how it was done but
you know for the most part Todd
McFarlane's first foray into like a
wholly-owned character he could do
anything he wanted to and that's why
people who read spawn love they
absolutely adore Todd McFarlane because
they watched him grow as a creator as he
was creating spawn right so if you were
somebody who was who started reading
spawn with issue number one and you've
been reading it ever since you were
growing with Todd for atomic farland as
he was doing it right so you were
watching him grow in real-time and it's
a cool experience right to be able to be
alongside a creator as they're getting
better and better at their craft but the
result of this is that basically this is
you know there's this particular guy
that spawn catches up to ends up offing
himself and in response to this they're
deemed to have been failures by 20
twists and so meeting with the rest of
the of the
bosses it's okay let's start calling in
a heavy hitter right let's call an
overkill is anybody against this and
they're all like nope take this guy out
right like kill this guy where this has
gone on long enough
and so with overt kill being called in
he ends up meeting spawn you know kind
of at these docks and initially you
would kind of look at this and say okay
so like if you look at it in hindsight
like you look at it spawn as you know
him now your initial thought would be
okay he's gonna overcome that guy quick
fast and in a hurry but the important
thing to understand is during these
early stories spawn was still learning
what he was capable of but he was still
learning about his powers there were
things that he could do that he didn't
know he could do the other part of this
is that was spawn using his power in
depleting his his necro plasm basically
as energy that if it goes on too long if
he uses too much power it drains to zero
he dies goes to hell and leads the
forces of mal bozhe right so this is
where the spawn come it got super
intriguing it's a guy who can
conceivably do pretty much anything but
chooses not to it's one of these things
works like if Superman acted like Batman
more or less that's kind of how this
goes down the issue with this is that
overkill is just kind of this
overwhelming force for any standard guy
out there using any real measure of
hand-to-hand combat especially if they
don't really seem to be as strong as
overkill is and so the initial foray
between himself and spawn
see spawn of course like ripping his arm
off everything is hand off but then like
overkill immediately gets the upper hand
and just starts pummeling it why just
absolutely swords pummeling spawn and
then leaves them for dead
now this is an important thing because
overt kill believes that spawn is dead
right he's just kinda like I've done my
job this guy's dead like we're just kind
of moving on and doing our own thing the
reality of this is that it seemed as
though the censors that overkill uses to
determine the heartbeats of others to
ensure that like they're they actually
are dead up here to basically be
malfunctioning and so when his mind
spawn is dead when in reality spawn is
not but what he has come to face-to-face
with is the fact that there are people
out there they can just overwhelm him
right especially if he's not really
using his abilities now again if he used
all of his various powers you would have
destroyed this guy right like overkill
would have been crushed quite readily
but Swann kind of goes back to the
drawing board and says okay I don't
really want to use my powers unless I
absolutely have to
so like I'm gonna go do what I do best
I'm gonna grab a bunch of weapons and
just like shoot stuff up and that's why
I spawn looks so cool right because this
single page for example when he's got
like his chains he's got like his ammo
he's got his guns these are like
hallmark depictions of spawn right like
these are the kind of things you think
of when he's
of Spawn especially back in the 1990s
just like over-the-top impossibly large
guns just different things like that
right so the result of this is that
locating Tony twist you know he really
just kind of like shoots the place up
but there is a little bit of a plot
thread that's introduced here and this
is what Todd McFarlane would do over the
course of the early stories a lot of
what took place between the time that
that Al Simmons died and then came back
we didn't really know right so like in
the early stories we didn't know how he
died we just knew that he was killed we
didn't know who pulled the trigger we
just knew that somebody pulled it we
didn't really know a lot of these these
intricacies these nuances of his
backstory and that's one of the things
that made him so intriguing and that's
why I Todd McFarlane's spawn succeeded
so well because it took everything that
was popular about like Wolverine for
example the mysterious backstory things
like that but it took that mystery of
like what's going on with his character
and then stretched it on not too long
that people in love people lost interest
but it didn't give us so much so fast
that there was no more mystery anymore
right so it was kind of the perfect
balance which is a very very difficult
thing to do which i think is really a
testament to how good of a writer Todd
McFarlane was but what we kind of get is
a sort of flashback where he recalls a
guy who basically had a gun and killed
him again we're only really shown this
person in terms of like bones and a
skull and so on so we don't really know
who this guy is but we know there was
some kind of Vendetta right like I would
have killed you for free you know nobody
would have had to pay me for it you know
when this guy considers Al Simmons to
have been a traitor so again kind of
building on this this mystery this
intrigue this origin that we're not
fully sure of and so as a result of that
he ends up basically tracking down Tony
twist ends up shooting up his office and
then basically says like have overt kill
meet me at this location at midnight I'm
not done yet the two of us are gonna go
forward and do our thing right so it's
kind of cool you know it's pretty
interesting because what this does it
leads to basically overkill showing up
here and when overkill shows up to
basically face off against spawn yet
again spawn kind of learns his lesson it
was very easy to get carried away with
himself in the first conflict right to
just kind of assume he could get the
upper hand on this guy as opposed to
kind of treating him with the route with
the sort of respect that you have to
treat somebody with when you're engaging
in any sort of a physical altercation
right you don't know what they're
capable of and so it's not really like
treating them with respect as a person
like I'm not gonna hit you as hard as I
can it's I don't know what you're
capable of so I'm going to assume you're
capable of anything
and plan accordingly and so realizing
the cybernetic enhancements that benefit
over kill one of the first things spawn
does is stab them through a cybernetic
eye and this has two major impacts the
first is that it takes away his
enhancements when it comes to his vision
and then to it removes his depth
perception and so depth perception you
know losing that basically means he
doesn't know how far away spawn is for
the most part it's all a two-dimensional
space now and it's kind of cool right
because spawn could be like 15 feet away
spawn could be like 5 feet away the only
way that overkill could judge this is
the size the objects in relation to
spawn around him right and so as a
result of that the two of them sort of
going at it you know and of course like
spawn sort of taunting over to kill by
basically like showing what his true
face looks like when he's you know
burned all the pieces and so on and so
forth but in this moment of arrogance an
overkill basically gets carried away
with himself spawn ends up rigging out
this colossal gun and blows a hole
through this guy and essentially kills
him right his whole cybernetic system
starts shutting down and then spawns
like done and then just kills him just
like that it's a quick fight but it's
very very fast and very very quick and
it makes sense that it would be that way
this this is really where it ends why
does it kind like okay so like over it
kills dead spawns like the cops are
gonna be called so it's time for me to
bail out but what this was designed to
do and the reason why it happened so
quickly is if you're not really familiar
with like McFarland's riding style you
would look at this and you would say
okay so this was like a really rushed
story when in reality it wasn't what it
was designed to do is to show spawn can
be defeated if he doesn't pay attention
to what he's doing
just because spawn has these abilities
doesn't mean that he's all-encompassing
impossible to destroy right especially
if he's not using his abilities what it
does is it's designed to kind of build
on the nature of the character and say
there's more to spawn than just a guy
who can like uses necrochasm and it's
chains and hooks and things like that
using your mind is just as important as
using your body effectively and it's a
really really cool ama because it builds
on the on the nature of the character
that's one of reasons why it proved to
be so resounding ly successful but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
too comments explained make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop all like and
yeah keep a lookout tomorrow we will
continue our spawn videos peace
I want to say thank you to all of the
new patrons who have joined patreon.com
slash comics explained I want to give a
shout out to Henry young - Elias G David
J s Jacob H been John H Jason see Austin
s Austin H James O kristymatt in Jeff
our Joey M Steven Z sloth-like lu-david
see John H lean and mean that guy asked
questions all the time Adam Cajun gnosis
916 I want to say thank you to all of
you all this list is growing all the
time leave it to the patreon
[Music]